hey everyone diavola here and in today's
video we're going to be going over
another of the most anticipated fights
in all of Jujutsu Kaizen this here is
the two fights that take place between
the freaking monoliths of opposite
strength in the series a seemingly
infinite amount of cursed energy while
The Prodigy himself Saturday Gojo and
his six eyes firstly most feared man yes
just a man with no curse energy at all
and the history of Jujutsu Kaizen that
being the Assassin toji fushiguro but
just before we do get into the video if
you are new around here and want to
watch similar explained content for a
multitude of different series then make
sure to hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like as it
really helps out with that whole YouTube
algorithm plus I'm only like 7K Subs
away from 100K now so it'd be absolutely
insane if we could reach that before the
end of even like October but anyway
enough of that I need to give you all a
slight bit of proteins around how we
made it to this exact moment here with
the Gojo vs toji fired so straight after
the events with the cursed When Death
painting Arc in the anime Gojo ends up
having a little bit of a Nana NAB
reminisces over his time and jiu Jutsu
High 11 years earlier by the way if you
do want to watch a full rundown of this
Arc and haven't already I'll leave a
link to my video down in the description
below but pretty much in short the
strongest Duo big kiddo and Gojo are
tasked with an extremely special Mission
which is to transport something called
the star plasma vessel who's actually a
chick called riko Armani but you know
like you can watch that video that I
left in the description and get a better
understanding of that to master tinken
so that he can merge into that person's
body and maintain the hole that he has
over due to your highest concealment
barriers and whatnot but anyway enough
of that so we actually start out on the
final day or day three of the star
plasma vessel escort Mission as the team
finally reaches Tokyo jijutsu High
through the foothills of Mount mushiro
they travel up a large set of stairs
through several parallel Tori Gates then
finally reaching the top of the
staircase ghetto announces that they've
now made it inside of the school's
barrier cementing their safety the two
girls are both relieved and everyone
thinks satoro for his hard work tired
from the extended periods of keeping his
Infinity active Gojo ignores the praise
though and cheekily says that the
babysitting is finally over however as
soon as Saturday activates the infinity
and lets down his guard a katana pierces
through his torso held by no one other
than the Demon Lord himself toji
fushiguro looking over his shoulder a
confused satoro asks if he knows him
from somewhere but toji tells them not
to worry about remembering a random
dude's name looking at him Gojo slightly
recognizes toji because earlier on in
life while still with his Xenon family
toddy once went to see the young Prodigy
he was a big deal even back then and was
the first and last person to ever notice
toji's prisons while out of the line of
sides back in reality toji reveals that
he had waited until Gojo was worn down
to strike stabbing him from behind in a
complete surprise to try and get away
satoru forces himself up into the air
while suguru summons a giant man eating
curse at a vow toji and suddenly after
securing him with the curse zuguru
rushes to his friend's side but Goji
assures her that his wound isn't too
severe as the moment he was stabbed he
reinforced himself with curse energy to
reduce taking any further damage goju
asks skido to take Rico and get out of
the area as he tries to quickly deal
with his random assassin suguru riko and
masato then leave the area as Toki
slashes his way out of the giant
hawkwoon curse and exercises it with a
new Katana that is slippery little
cursed that huddles around and fed to
him toji looks around for the vessel but
satoru tells them that the bounty has
already been lifted however it is in
revealed through toji that he was
actually the person who set everything
up in the first place he used the
original payment that was given to him
by the star religious group to hire a
plethora of different assassins to wear
down Gojo's six eyes so we eventually
would lick down his guard and through
that he would create some sort of
opening which is like so big brain this
is why toji is the freaking goat yeah he
got cash money for doing the job and
he's already got money in the bank but
his ultimate goal is a Personal
Achievement of taking down the height of
curse energy so that he himself feels
fulfilled like the dude is utterly a
monster only consumed with strength
Saturday understands toji's plan and
begins his offensive by generating a
field of Attraction behind his opponent
using the illustrious curse technique
lapse blue however Koji is incredibly
fast and his reflexes are just utterly
superior to the younger gojos he's not
only able to avoid the attack but
instantly covers enough ground to move
from where he is to the roof behind Gojo
this makes Saturn realize that toji has
absolutely zero curse energy meaning
that he's using nothing but an innate
physical prowess to fight toji switches
out his curse tools and blitzes saturno
using a random Jagged path too fast for
anyone to even follow with the naked eye
toji think it's an extremely close and
goes to slice's opponent yet satsuro
manages to blast them back with blue
synonym shooting into a building as Gojo
advances he recognizes that his opponent
knows about the Limitless technique and
likely has a plan against dirt toji he
was in front of him the inventions from
Gojo's site into the nearby build and
due to the Heavenly restriction our big
Reigns sexualized user can't sense him
at all without any other choices left
satoru decides to clear the entire area
so that toji can't hide and again uses
his curse technique laps maximum curse
energy output blue doing this goju
creates a giant field of attraction that
tears up all of the buildings in the
area destroying them and leaving nowhere
for tochi to hide but somehow toji
manages to get around this and uses a
giant swarm of flyheads to distract him
seeing this goju expands the infinity
around him to keep the curses away and
surmises that toji is using them like a
chaff grenade which for those unsure a
chaff grenade is simply a cylindrical
type of grenade that upon exploding
releases thin pieces of electromagnetic
particles this chaff interferes with
electronic devices like laser sensors
and radar systems so like in this case
think of goju's infinity as almost a
radar type system that he uses to pick
up an object coming towards him because
of this Gojo is completely unable to
locate his opponent and even considers
the possibility that they sorcerer
killer left to go after his main target
due to this he looked in the direction
where suguru and the others went making
a fatal error in that moment toji
instantly appears above him Gojo notices
in time but as six eyes recognize the
different type of curse energy flowing
out of toji's new cursed toll because of
this weird feeling Gojo quickly goes on
the defensive but sadly this only seals
has faked it's then explained that this
dopas looking weapon which is a special
grade curse tool called the inspirit and
spirited called the inverted Spear of
Heaven nullifies the effect of any
cursed technique even Limitless in
reality toji stabs Gojo through the neck
with the inverted Spear of Heaven
leaving Gojo completely defend slush
Gojo desperately reaches for the dagger
as he bleeds from the mouth but toji
acts quickly and cuts into Saturday's
torso then takes out a second knife and
finishes the job by rapidly stabbing
Gojo's leg forcing him to collapse into
directly being stared through the
forehead by toji's knife appearing to
have been absolutely destroyed Saturday
delays and a pull of his own blood as
toji claims he's finally getting back
into the groove of things so yeah I
can't remember I said this or not but
this isn't even prime toji that monster
comes out during Shibuya but he's still
somehow took down the strongest sorcerer
alive at that time on the planet so well
obviously that can't be the end of the
video as we all know Gojo isn't actually
dead in the current timeline so if you
do want a more detailed rundown of what
happens in between here and the rematch
then be sure to go and check out my Gojo
past Arc video like I've said at the
beginning and now where I go over the
entire story before and after this point
up until the Shibuya incident Arc but
pretty much all that you guys need to
know for in between the two fights as
that toji manages to complete his
mission and deliver the star plasma
vessel to the time vessel Association
however as this mofo is leaving the area
something he probably can't even
comprehend happens unbelievably he runs
and we're restored and awakened sasuro
Gojo who's Delirious on the increase of
strength that he's just achieved
standing in front of them toji is taken
aback to see someone he was sure he
killed not too long ago crazed from
using both these six eyes and the
Limitless to defend himself Gojo begins
explaining how when he was at the very
edge of death he experienced and
understood the core of cursed energy
insulted by the idea that he could have
already lost toji takes out the inverted
Spear of heaven and claims that the
battle is just beginning to which Gojo
gets excited agreeing with toji so sorry
to cut everything off here again but I'm
pretty sure goju would have even
achieved the state someday like by where
we are in a story at the moment even if
toji wasn't the one to bring it on but
we can definitely thank toji for
bringing on the invincibility level aura
that surrounds Gojo in the current
timeline because it's just utterly
unreal what is about to happen tochi
attempts to Blitz satsudo dashing in and
unloading a monstrous lift swing but
Saturday who doesn't even seem to be
worried is simply able to levitate above
him to avoid it while upside down in the
ear sasuredo uses the same concept of
reverse curse technique and flows the
reverse curse energy and towards
Limitless unleashing the curse technique
reversal red from the tip of his fingers
a massive energy wave shoots forth as it
connects it seems totally flying across
the area and clean through another
building getting up from The Hectic
attack hoji stretches out his arm and
confirms that the energy wave didn't
break any of his bones he then breaks
down each of the logistics behind a
technique of Limitless he goes over the
three main abilities of the Limitless
watch he thinks our Infinity red and
blue and takes it a middle chain from
his curse he connects this chain to the
end of the inverted sphere of heaven and
believes the infinity red or blue won't
be an issue any longer with his added
range toji comes up with a
countermeasure for each but there is
still a heavy uneasiness rested on his
shoulders that he can't seem to shake he
locks eyes will start to do and decides
to ignore this uneasiness for now and
initiate the battle once more as toji
begins to rapidly spin around his new
upgraded weapon Saturday apologizes to
Rico for not being able to save her but
claims that himself alone is the honored
one quoting the freaking Buddha himself
toji then uses the Chang to tear apart
the ground creating a wave of debris
that Force Saturn Ohio into the air
suddenly the inverted Spear of Heaven
appears from the dust cloud right in
front of Gojo toji then flicks the chain
sending the curse tool flinging directly
at Saturday who isn't moving quickly
enough through the ear to avoid Earth as
Gojo floats there he thinks that the
info on inherited techniques often get
out between other sorcerer families so
he guesses that the Assassin is probably
from the Xenon family however there is
even a technique and a limitless Arsenal
that is only known to a few within the
prized Gojo family the awakened
Limitless user then combines both red
and blue and unleashes an imaginary mass
of curse energy that erases absolutely
everything it touches the infinite
Hollow technique purple as the ability
flies out it instantly connects with the
entire left side of toji's torso
vaporizing half of his chest by breaking
his metal chain and ending his offensive
in one powerful motion defeated toji
realizes that his uneasiness stemmed
from him breaking his own rule he knows
that he should have said he doesn't work
for free and made a run for it but the
greatest sorcerer alive stood before him
like I said earlier doji wanted to
discredit it and crush it despite the
Jiu Jitsu world and the zidden family
however tovi's self-affirmation caused
him to deviate from his true self and at
that point he had already lost
unfortunately for him toji was unable to
put aside his pity pride and because of
that he sealed his fate standing over
him now Gojo asks if toji has any last
words initially he claims he doesn't
have anything to say however after a
moment he remembers his young son and
tells Gojo how his son migami will be
sold to the Xenon family in two or three
years and to do as he pleases with that
information
and you know obviously we know what Gojo
did with that information is Mega me is
who he is currently in the story with
fushiguro still being his last name and
obviously if you've read ship or your
Arc as well then you know like
throughout Shibuya when they do finally
make father and son and he hears that he
still got the last name fujikuro he's
absolutely stoked so stoked in fact that
he ends up killing himself which is you
know absolutely insane but obviously if
you guys have enjoyed this video and
want to watch more stuff just like it
especially the fights where I go over
like individual fights that I've done in
the past but kind of like re-edit them
like I have here and add a little bit
more into the script and just kind of
update them to the kind of level of
editing and all that kind of jazz that
I'm at right now if you guys want more
of that stuff then let me know down in
the description below because this was a
little bit of a shorter video and it
kind of gives me a break in between
making those super long you know like
massive hour and a half two hour long
videos that I do for the bigger arcs of
the anime and it gives me time to like
work on them in the background and still
have a video come out which I kind of
like it makes sense for the channel to
try and you know like try and upload as
much as I can in between things but
anyway as I said if you guys have
enjoyed this video then do make sure you
hit the Subscribe button if you are new
around here and also do make sure you
hit that like button we are only like
seven or like 6K away from 100K Subs now
so that's freaking amazing and I can't
actually wait to finally get that silver
plaque but obviously enough of it for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diabolo and I will see you
all in a pert bye
freaking here still wait for my shower